hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play I can't escape
I bet I can buy David mullets
chase Bethea and John Gow ski and
Natalie Millette so let's get into it
we recommend playing in a dimly lit room
with your speaker or headphone volume
turned oh please move the slider to set
the brightness of the boxes below is
just barely visible I can barely see it
now but and that doesn't seem to be
doing anything so let's just go good
enough hello oh hi what the hell
wait a minute what oh okay oh ooh I have
to use some mouse keys to UM to navigate
in the very strict fashion like one of
those old dungeon crawlers oh man I
haven't played a game like this in
forever hello I wonder what diabolical
entities await me in the dark physic
that's just a music there's actually
really cool I'm in the game itself is
like maybe five megabytes so to see this
is pretty interesting its kind of
harkens back to the days of before there
was a lot of bloatware you know when
games were like really strict on their
resource consumption and very very very
cool what they've been able to do here
so ha what happened I fell hi dug a hole
down I should know better than to dig
down I think I see a key on the ground
over here is that the key out what is
that what is that oh oh what is behind
me I picked up another key I think I'm
not even sure what the hell what the
hell is going on I don't even know
ah ha ha ha ha I climbed up straight
through the floor because I did not want
to be there a second longer
I got like 10,000 keys fall down uh oh
no ok so I didn't
what is with those footsteps man you
need to stop messing with my brain
Oh dead end oh boy can I get through
here fast through it you bass right
through the ground come on man don't
mess with me there's something out here
there's some here another key man I'm
getting a lot of keys but to what I
don't know dead end
there's something in here and there
here's another Yap I don't want to be I
needed that key I think there seemed to
be just random place where you can fall
down traps or something I don't know go
away
is it the Minotaur I've dealt with
Minotaur spa
ah honey way ready we're as bad as I can
which is it very fast but I'm running
away ah fudge I'm not even father I
don't like this I don't like this at all
I don't like this at all at all at all
at all at all at all
no thank you
what the hell was that thing oh come on
what the hell that's not good why are
you doing that okay all right okay all
right okay all right okay all right okay
all right okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm
okay dad I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead and
done and done I'm done I'm done and done
I know damn it this is keep going the
monster I'll have to hold the ground i
frickin saw that one
what's with the tribal music
ah that's an eyeball hello hey dick so
what's with the sound here am I just
going [ __ ] down I don't want to go
farther down oh oh come on there's no
way out of here
I'm trapped forever hello I'm amazed at
how in-depth this game is that's a hole
in the ground see I can see just there
there's a hole in the ground and that
way too I do not want to go any farther
down than I need to I need to get out of
here now
I need to go home it's almost as if I
can't escape what is that on the ground
I season okay it looks like my only way
is down I like being here I don't like
any of this none of this is good to me
very bad very bad very bad okay we're
okay though we are just mud or nothing
so long as the monster doesn't show up I
should be fine okay all right let's do
some actual game commentary here and
stuff just being a whiny little baby um
it's really like I've said before
there's a lot of minimalistic approach
to this that I definitely appreciate
because um I used to love these little
dungeon crawler games before and there's
actually almost there's actually a
recent game made like this but I've
forgotten the name of it my brother
played it before how good I can finally
go up on now I fell down there's a hole
under the ladder you
you dick you Ray you really don't want
me to escape do you I've gotten so many
keys I just don't know what they're for
the atmosphere is really great I mean I
love it there are all these weird noises
I don't um that I don't know where it's
coming from and the way the movement
works it's very restrictive so that I
feel like I like there's something
behind me and I can't respond very
quickly if it's there it's got to wait a
minute was that AA secret huh its Rick I
really like it in a lot of ways it's
something that you don't see a lot of
nowadays because that's Kyle Austin
perfectly 3d movement but this is
actually really cool and I'm actually
now seeing all those secrets so that's
that's good
I saw that ladder before how do I get
back to there we got I got more keys
that I know what something happening on
that one
oh no though oh I want to go home
how let me go home it's weird because
I'm like terrified if that monster
showing up even though I've only seen
him once
it's like mind-bendingly terrifying okay
anyway there's another key which I do
not need I finally decided that I
actually don't need keys cuz I'm so far
down I don't know how I'm ever gonna get
back up ridiculous this is ridiculous
oh my goodness oh come on I don't even
see that one oh well I'm just boned ah
what the yeah what is that another
demonic butthole uhh
what this place is aha
who are you what day I where to go I
want to be here I don't want to be here
I don't want to be here
oh no I better come on I'm so far down
now
I've been you know where I am I talk to
me anger there was something there I
know I saw something no it was that
white thing whatever that white thing
was that was there right before I fell
it was gonna get me ah come on
oh no oh no oh no oh I'm trapped now
it's getting darker ah no oh
oh man that was horrifying that was
horrifying
that was awesome but horrifying that was
really amazing
I mean I'm that was an exceptionally
well made game a but exceptionally well
made working and actually gave the
feeling that I was lost and alone and
trying desperately to find a way out
that I was never gonna find I don't know
even know if that was the only ending
and it probably was a way out but given
that it's the name of the game is I
can't escape I might guess not but
either way that was a tremendous game I
loved every second of it that was really
really really something incredible and
something you guys have to try out um
check the link in the description below
it's an amazing game so atmospheric and
so like perfectly and what's great as it
plays off of what a horror game should
be I did not see much of those monsters
I didn't even die from a monster and I
was terrified to ever come near one like
I don't know there were two different
types it was a black one with the red
eyes that only popped up for a little
bit and I ran straight away from and
then there was the white one I don't
even know what that one was all about
but either way it was great because the
controls fit perfectly with the theme of
the game like you had it was boxing you
had to turn 90 degrees to run away and
then when it that way when a monster
came you actually yeah you actually
couldn't get away fast enough and that
feeling of panic that you can't get away
is what really made it scary for me like
I oh man and the constant falling down I
mean I I literally couldn't see anything
it was really dark in that game I'll try
to bump it up for you guys but either
way you've got to try it on your own
it's from gamejolt um it's really
incredible to try it for yourself so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye-bye
ah
Oh
buzz